everybody it's Mike from order Flows at
Saturday uh September 24th and you know
I want to make this video to sort of
follow up on some of my more recent
videos dealing with size in the market
and you know what's stopping volume and
what you know volume means basically to
strength of the market and you know I'm
going to look at some other markets
today besides the equities you know some
of these commodity markets in my opinion
follow the order flow much better than
you know markets like equities where you
have a lot of
hot money coming into the market you
know you got a lot of retail Traders you
got a lot of money that's uh just sort
of coming into the market for no other
reason than it needs to a place to sit
whereas when you're trading Commodities
those are not cash settled contracts
they're physically delivered and
majority of the Traders the overwhelming
majority of the Traders there are people
that are
trading it to because they need it right
they need to make something with it you
know they need to make cereal in the
case of you know grains you know or
copper they need to make pipes so the
participants are using it
trading that market you know for hedging
purposes for taking delivery
Etc so it tends in my opinion to follow
supply and demand much better than some
of these other markets that just have a
lot of hot money coming in and out of
the market you know how money is money
coming from all sorts of different
sources for different reasons as opposed
to markets that are more concentrated by
um
producers by uh I can't think of the
term now
um I don't say consumers but you know um
you know end users that's the term I'm
looking for you know people buying it
because they need it okay and based off
of actual supply and demand of that
market based on what they're
manufacturing so
corn okay corn is a is a great market
for trading you know sometimes it's a
very boring Market to look at because
you don't get much price movements but
when it starts moving you know to me
it's like one of those sleeping Giants
right it's it's got plenty of volume
it's good enough to trade but you just
don't get that volatility you know
Traders don't see that type of
volatility as they would in equities
right I mean people seem to be attracted
more to the action of the markets rather
than the actual Market itself
but there are good moves to be had in
the grains and sort of follow up
from
some of the more recent videos on where
heavy volume is going to be you know the
higher the day the low of the day
is your immediate support and resistance
level it's the reason there's a reason
it's the highest the reason it's the low
right you have the resistance at the
high of your support at the low so it's
not uncommon to see the heaviest volumes
of the day sort of being transacted down
there at these lows
so you see this is corn this is on
Friday the 23rd right as we're coming
down making new losers decent volume you
know 300 traded on the bid 300 600
um you know getting down here it's it's
another sales at 689. here's a thousand
contracts people say oh my gosh you know
we traded 600 we got through it okay but
you know just because you have that
heavy volume there right that's where
you're expecting it to be right don't
get so excited that you know there's
heavy volume here in the Market's
getting through it right the market is
finding its balance and sometimes it has
to get through some size to get there
where volume is going to be more
relevant is if you start seeing heavy
volume
coming in
around an area you had been trading
around an area that you've been rotating
around and maybe you're starting to
leave that area that's where I think
you're going to get more value out of
um the volume so to speak that now you
have
fresh buyers coming in or fresh sellers
coming in whereas these you know some of
these bids they could have been sitting
here for weeks or you know days at least
because we're at the lows you know we're
at you know daily lows we're at you know
we're below the previous days lows Etc
so you tend to have you know volumes
around those areas because
if you have a support level in the
market right the end users right the
people that want to buy it cheap
yeah they'll be loving to buy it at the
lows of the day or just below the low of
the day in case we dip down below and
then rally up you know that that's
that's their best place that they can
buy it they don't want to be buying it
uh as the market starts rallying so if
they could have some bids in there and
they happen to get filled then they're
happy
so just because you see you know these
big volumes
coming in down here at these lows don't
get you know you're oh my gosh you got
this big volume coming in here that's
where it's expected to be so let me give
you a good example okay so you know we
got down to Arlo of uh 669 and a half
now granted you know these volumes the
1066.
Battle of Hastings the 689
um you know the 609 these are coming in
at the lows the rest of the volumes that
you're seeing here
um you know sort of the heavier volumes
are in the hundreds 154 113 179 179
um you know here's a 200 here's a 300
you know but 267 and again 100 100 174
so now you guys start looking and
concentrating on rather focusing on
where the bigger volumes are coming in
okay so what's happened here so our low
is here 844 669 and a half
um let's make these charts a little bit
easier to read now let's start looking
at what's where the volumes are coming
in so the market started going up we're
trading in this range here 673 down to
671 so you know basically a two cent
range but you're not really seeing any
big volumes go through here you know 112
133 starts getting bit up here 269
coming in here on the bid at 674. now
that what's interesting about this is
you have this stacked buying imbalance
and then it turns it bid here so I got a
big buyer coming in they had about 500
contracts to buy here
okay so they they swept it up from 673
and a half all the way up to four and a
quarter turned it bit
did you get much follow through a little
bit right it got all the way up to uh
five and a quarter and then it came
right back down to that
she had this binding balance on the way
up then you got selling and balance sort
of at the same level
okay so while I do like this price
activity taking place here the sweep you
know the big order coming through and
turning a bid I don't like the fact that
it couldn't build on it in the next bar
it just went two ticks higher and then
went sideways for the next five minutes
and finally got done through it but you
know what I know that at this area right
even though this trade didn't pan out
again you know you could have bought it
in here you know even if you bought it
up here at five and a quarter you know
you're gonna get out of it at you know
three and a half three and a quarter so
it's you know two cent stop
okay you know you gotta have stops in
there that is normally a very bullish
activity
didn't work out
but you know you start recognizing it
that it's not working out by going
sideways on all this area in here
but if you didn't you got stopped out
you lost a couple cents two cents then
it just sort of hung around here again
and again it's just hanging again around
the 672 and a half area
um you know it does trade up to four and
a half just sort of hanging around in
here hanging around
hanging around not really going anywhere
now it starts to tick up here again
all right you see the 133 that's some
decent size but it doesn't really go
anywhere right but there's nothing
really actionable in this order flow now
some Traders will say Mike why should I
bother in corn there's nothing going on
it's it's basically 674 and a half bid
offered at three quarters sometimes it
goes down to four and a quarter bid four
and a half offer like that you can see
that
taking place for how many minutes you
know three straight minutes it's boring
that's that's why Traders aren't
interested in this but again you know if
you start watching knowing what to look
for
the bar that comes in like this is the
payoff bar okay you see buying a balance
buying a balance buying balance 303 10
on the offer here at five and a half
it got through that it went bid at five
and a half offered at five and three
quarters didn't trade five and three
quarters then just sort of came down
here and then it finally started poking
up and then from
675 and three quarters you know all the
way up to you know the 679 area right in
here
so that was a decent move up right there
but this was the sign the volume going
through now I like this volume earlier
when we were right in here this was
coming at four and a quarter
okay now it's coming in just slightly
higher at uh five and a half so about uh
what one and a half cents higher
but you finally get that move up this is
the move that you're looking for
with the volume now remember volume is
relative right so if you're trading a
certain Market you got to understand
what's heavy volume 300 the strong
volume
at a price in the corn on a one minute
chart
now let's move on to another Market here
real quick let's look at Copper because
you know copper is an interesting Market
you know copper is a commodity used in
construction right it's used in in pipes
for hot water and it's got a lot of
other instruct uses in construction
but what I want to talk about here again
this is a market this is Friday
coming you know accomplish one of these
markets it's got a you know the lme the
London Metal Exchange
is very active Market in Copper
obviously the comex copper is a
different contract but
when the lme market is open you tend to
get a pickup in volume
in the comex copper so you can trade
comex you know in the early morning you
can see here this is four in the morning
it's got decent volumes going through
400 contracts 400 500 here you get those
small volume ones the 110 116 346 but
you know you're getting decent volumes
400 500 contracts
and you can see as we're coming down
into making these new lows you know
there there are there is volume down
here you can see there's 102 that traded
here with the 34 it's 140 you know 109
164. you know 82 100 so that was about
300 contracts sitting down here at this
level
so you're starting to get a concept of
what heavier volume is in Copper right
just by looking at this market and then
seeing okay well here's a 50 up in here
this is these are trap Traders up in
here that's why this is a Red Zone being
drawn out the dark red is telling me
that it's uh these guys are stuck in the
market they're trying to buy it Go long
but they're they're trapped by the way
54 is a strong number
okay we're just coming it's coming on
the offer so this Market went up going
sideways trading sideways
buyers are coming in here but I got a
strong offer in the market sort of
keeping pressure on this Market
from going any higher
and sells back off down towards the lows
and eventually does make a slightly New
Low by a tick
um
and then again you know it's just sort
of rotating around 63 it's heavy volume
but again that's at the low of the day
that's your support
and people so how do you know that's a
short it's the law of the day by
definition that's your support area
there's a reason why it's a little day
because someone's interested in trading
it lower so anyway here's the market
came right back down you know it went
from uh
what is this uh 334 25 all the way down
to uh 333 20. then you've seen some
heavy volumes transact down here
because remember what I said you know
about 50 contracts is heavy volume
on a one minute chart in Copper
especially at this time of the day you
know six seven in the morning
and you can see again some support
coming in here right you see that's why
this point of control is down here
because that's where the volume is
transacting every time it comes down
here it trades about 50 60 contracts it
rallies back up
okay people say what about this 95 here
okay well so there was a bid there but
it just got whacked
right and close below that uh point of
control but really what was interesting
is there's a couple of levels in here
foreign
you can see up in here right the 111
okay even though it's a green candle
we're still closing right on that point
of control next two are lower what was
interesting the 106 that came in here so
we went up you had a strong seller up in
here you get another strong seller a
little bit lower Marcus does rally back
up towards that level then comes off and
then we rally back up where right to
that previous point of control right in
here right you can see right
right here right
it came right back up then went back
down
and later we rally back up we get up to
this uh 334.90 area this time look at
this right point of control right on top
you've got 40 contracts up there 40 26
15.
this bars traded 183 contracts he got 40
66 76 81 contracts just under half the
volume trading at these three prices so
I know there's some stopping volume
there's some heavy volume up there
okay Market sells off off of that
then it comes back up
gets couples
you know like what is that what six
seven ticks lower and then boom you get
the point of control right on the top of
this bar
53 contracts trade right there right
one-fourth of the volume of this bar
trades right up here at this level
and what happens
Market sells off again this is what I
talked about point of controls on the
extreme in the beauty of the order flows
Trader software
is I have it turned off right now
because I'm trying to make this video
for people that don't have the software
on on what to look for but you know we
have this function here
Prominent Point of controls if you were
to enable it
now the order flow software you know
when it highlights it it makes it very
easy to see right as Traders I like to
think you know we're very visual people
especially nowadays you know with social
media we're always scrolling through our
phones you know looking at Instagram
looking at Pinterest you know Facebook
even
um we just look at the images or or
videos in this case we're looking at
images the Mind processes images very
quickly so you know having something
there to highlight it to you is telling
you hey you know what you might want to
short this and you can immediately just
scalp it you know for
how many ticks that you want to get out
of it
alright guys well anyway I'll end that
video there for today be sure to uh
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
already you know I realize some of these
videos are
um
how to subscribe you know aren't as
scripted you know some people they like
to write all these elaborate scripts on
the market and stuff but yeah I just
like to pull up the charts and discuss
it you know this isn't like trades that
I was that I that I took or anything
like that it's more for educational
purposes right what I saw on the markets
um on this day or maybe after the
markets closed you know and I'm looking
through some charts you know just point
out some things so that when you're
trading especially if you're using order
flow these are things you can look for
all right so thanks everyone have a
great weekend bye-bye